pour terminer nous allons danser mais au
rythme de la techno en tout cas des
milliers de personnes se sont laissé
aller cet après-midi dans les rues de
paris emporté par trois cent mille
boîtes de musique électronique
la techno parade 2004 vécue par fabrice
turpin et georges lui donc la folie
techno a déferlé dans les rues de paris
deux cent à trois cent mille tupper
attiré par un déluge de sons une
trentaine de chars et plus de 150 dj
à paris cet après-midi décidément tout
était permis
c'est papier tellement techno la nar
anon manhattan ou sonabel
trou dans son coup d'arrêt
boîte de nuit improvisée ou rois du
système d
rien n'est assez excentrique c'est ça la
techno attitude mais la technoparade
accueilli cette année aussi un groupe de
percussionnistes africains
une façon pour la musique électronique
de retrouver ses origines ethniques tire
sa source d weekly balle dans le dos et
non ceux qui étaient naturelles étaient
prêtés par des compensées par la
technologie
la technologie en question et les
racines ya pas de différence de nature
hier que tu penses de degrés mais la
techno traîne toujours sa mauvaise
réputation certaine personnalité un peu
rare c'était donc jointe au cortège pour
la soutenir il ya eu des moments très
difficiles
voilà été pourchassés poursuivi
qui communiait ça va mieux
c'est pas encore ça à chaque époque mais
très sa propre musique et à chaque fois
cette forme d'expression musicale amarré
en rupture
alors
je suis
ah ah
créée en 1998 pour promouvoir la musique
électronique
la techno parade a en tout cas rempli sa
mission faire danser paris